hello I go back to game sports
continuing coverage of e3 2015 one of my
favorite things to do at e3 is play fifa
early and once again the cannon is over
in the u.s. to show it off very good
looking forward to a new year of FIFA
and it's been interesting moving over
here and seeing the growth of a
footballer I guess I'd say soccer when
I'm here in North America yeah and it's
it's great that you guys are sort of
growing into new areas as well talk
about at the addition of a ladies
football in a second but first of all
let's let's look at the game we've got a
real madrid vs barcelona here and let me
know what new gameplay additions you are
you making lots of things i mean we
really we've taken a step back in the
development team this year really look
to our game and look at all the systems
we have great technology but let's look
at all those systems and what do we need
to do to improve innovate refine
everything and and listening to the
feedback from the players that play our
game to give us great feedback and there
was a couple of key things that stood
out one was really one better more
confidence in defending they want to be
able to defend it was difficult at times
when that game was a little bit in
balance last year with the speedy speedy
wingers the skilled players so we want
to create a really balanced game because
all teammates make a fun experience also
getting the midfield back they wanted to
be able to build up through the midfield
so really shaping our feature set around
that so we got a few examples here right
now we're going to show you right now is
here this is just one example of a lot
of work we've done around player
movements will move this forward if you
actually look at Neymar number 11 there
you'll cease do what we call a swing
step so this is a really agile turn a
quick way to keep with bail you know
previously you'd overshoot you know what
run him it was difficult to keep up so
this is just one example of responsive
player movement that we've worked on to
really help you keep with those players
getting helping that balance because we
we don't want to take away that the
dribbling everyone really enjoyed that
layers nice and this is an example of
defending again this is actually team
that this is a I and your team mates
working with you so we look at the right
back there at the bottom of the screen
you'll notice as a change of possession
he instantly comes back to get back
defensively get back in position last
year it took a little bit too long it
was a good chance that the winger there
was was in on goal and yeah you know you
to bring the center back home obviously
this is real madrid so presumably for
playing with scunthorpe there might be
as quick on the obviously the attributes
the ratings are balanced across all the
different teams but fundamentally the
teams will still have that intelligence
to be able to cover and and this is
another one here so again a change your
possession here and the game previously
very much focused on man-to-man marking
didn't really take come away from the
player market to cover so we look at the
top of the screen racket it you'll
notice is covering a player there and
Benzema gets the ball so he notices that
bails making a great run so he comes
over to cover it's just something we
didn't have a lot of previous then it
felt like you'd be quite exposed at
about yeah and also going forward
sometimes we felt like there was a
sometimes that there's nothing more
frustrating then when you see a run
yourself and they don't actually make up
ourselves yeah those it was quite a few
times with players to be in on goal at
center backs wouldn't cover for each
other you know the full-backs wouldn't
come over to cover either which was a
little bit frustrating so this is
another example of just a new mechanic
we've redone all of our slide tackle
animations and we actually added some
new functionality where marchello comes
in here he's got a slight he's going to
commit to a slide tackle previously
slide tackles were great they work but
if you miss you kind of out of the play
yeah we've rewired the messy recognizes
he's coming in slides manases the dink
the ball over him if you press the slide
tackle button again he'll pop up we
branch out violation so you again much
more responsive you get back into the
play one of the things they're you
innovated on a couple years ago was with
the second defender price and then it's
sort of its specially in 1v1 play it
ended up being problematic because you
just had players like swarming the
opposition and with that mechanic with
the slide tackle is there a worried you
might have people using it too much like
diving in and even like faking a dive
tackle to try and make somebody attack
in a different way yeah so it's a really
good point we actually have added fake
tackles this year sorry yeah you had
that you know again with those
one-on-one situations you can kind of
faint to try and you know go for a
tackle and then hold back but and
there's a really good point and I
talking about balance we want a really
balanced game so we're working a
teammate back in vancouver's working
really hard to make sure you know we
added these mechanics but we're working
around them making sure that you know
nothing too overpowering so this is then
sort of more focus now on the midfield
again
an offensive thing but we've really
upped the intelligence around
interception so this is our interception
logic you can see the balls going into
benzema here p case tight but he takes
two he takes a bit of a risk but he
actually goes and aggressively tries to
intercept the ball and does it obviously
if he misses it's a sort of risk reward
thing but here's another example now
with racket it's again he wants to
aggressively get the ball so he comes in
and slide tackle a slide story to as he
get the interception so this has really
transformed the game when you play the
game this is what's bringing that build
up play back into the midfield because
you can't blindly pass you can't pop
passes around without worrying about you
know getting the ball intercepted this
really has changed the feeling of the
game so you think maybe the sort of that
there was very much a feeling that when
you had possession in fifa15 that you
could sort of it was almost up to you to
try and score as opposed to the defense
being able to stop you I'd like a look
absolutely and again it's a little bit
more of a considered approach people
having to think maybe having a very
their tactics not just using speed as we
did Ali a little bit too much last year
this is an example here of actually that
balance in the counter so this is what
we call passing the purpose so crews
here is going to pick a pass this is
right bumper with pass and you can
actually hit a pass up more powerfully
at higher speed this allows you to get
through gaps as you can see here master
on it will react but because the players
there's more paste on the past you can't
get there in time but presumably that's
a direct parse it's not like a through
pass you have to leave okay straight
anything so I'm gonna have to pick that
one yes of course yeah give you that
opportunity to counter the interception
so again adding to the balance so this
is a new mechanic this is trying to get
a few more moments of magic in here did
a lot in dribbling last year we've added
this mechanic what we call no touch
dribbling which means when you hold down
left bumper you don't actually touch the
ball okay dribbling around with left
stick you dribble as normal but if you
think about modern football and good
players they use body faints yes they
don't touch the ball they're like fake
to go one way so we've added that so
here's an example here normal message at
dribbling for Messi then he faints fakes
to pass hold down left bumper here and
as you'll see he fails to go one way
then the other and then explodes out
when you release it that's interesting
one of my favorite parts of
of doing ice that I love holding and
shoot and then hitting pastor exact
ain't a ton of the things you guys
managed to do and with the AI was
actually have them react to that
realistically I presumably it takes a
lot of work to do that and that's easy
and it's one of the nice things it gives
you another a bit more variety in attack
and you don't have to do skill moves so
we've obviously still have skill moves
in the game we're adding some new ones
but it's just a new way to do it
probably a little bit easier to do than
than actually a combination around skill
moves so it's just another another
mechanic to break down a defender here's
another example of it while sprinting
here you'll see here now they're just as
a little body faint they're not touching
the ball and then explodes out and rise
a challenge so X a really nice mechanic
a lot of this stuff I always felt was
like it was great and you know you
showing off a rail and by a Barcelona
and you know when you actually try and
play as your favorite team yeah
especially with the skill moves like you
can't really do a lot of okay and we
were talking before we went live about
how whenever you play online as well
people tend to pick the biggest team how
can you compare doing that while still
making that that gap realistic this is
really what we're trying to do here is
if you make a more balanced game a game
where you know you have to vary the
attack the key here is by having to
build up through the midfield you can't
rely on those wingers why did people
play with real madrid well they had bail
on one side and and ronaldo on the other
if you're now obviously we still want
you to be able to attack we still want
your gel to dribble with the ball but if
you're having to think about and more
considered play you're more likely to
use different teams right now by making
these chasing the game or encouraging
people to think that way and you know
last year there was a tactic of paste it
was very over pervasive and that's why
people defaulted to that team yeah maybe
also over Barcelona you know so and
works well I play as Arsenal and I'm
adapted I liked it a lot yes I online or
lose so here's another example of
touching every area in racing across the
entire pitch this is crossing so we're
now getting the ball in behind the
defenders and leading the attacker more
it was much more square crosses before
and we're actually leading Benzema here
onto the ball and he's able to actually
come in here and X ollie so the final
thing just to show you in the replays is
shooting again we were shooting
obviously was incredibly rewarding at
times last year there was the ball fell
a bit floaty so we want more driven
shots so we're
actually much more realistically looking
at how you hit the ball where but also
the sort of 3d nature of the foot so
this is a square driven shot and you'll
notice the trajectory is much more
driven and powerful than last year this
is an example here where he actually
gets his foot around the ball a little
bit more and you think this is a Fernet
shot this is actually a driven shot and
it curls oh wow a little bit more and
then finally if you come across the ball
as Benzema does here it'll spin away
thanks a lot more variety so really
bringing that in there so you know we're
really trying to innovate across the
entire pitch for opening a lot of time
on gameplay obviously working on
goalkeepers which putting as much effort
this year in gold yeah laughs last year
massimo using a few frustrations so
really working on IDing out any issues
but also innovating there too and
innovating in types of the types of
football are available there women's
football coming to FIFA massive
announcement a couple of months ago and
really sort of groundbreaking in that
there are very few sort of modern sports
games that do that tennis is something
that comes to mind like I even like the
tiger games always do with that much
yeah I was talking to the NFL game guys
beforehand now they've got women in the
crowds right they didn't have female
spectator right so how long have you
guys been working on getting this into
fief we've been working on if about
three years we did up we did a prototype
about about three years ago now where we
actually put a female head on a man's
body we did it we did that for a reason
to say okay we're all the gaps you know
when we bring women into our game we
want to do it well we want to do it
properly wanted to be authentic so it
kind of created a sort of laundry list
of things we felt we needed to do to do
it properly and the biggest thing was
around the body scaling very linear in
the way we scaled our bodies and for the
men it went well and it was fine but to
do the woman's body type properly we
needed to scale more around shoulders
here and there not kind of effective
that is this actually meant that for men
we can actually do give more variation
in body types or rule out looks more
realistic which is you know it's great
you know we also wanted to get hair
simulation in there we could do that for
the men but it wasn't a priority because
there weren't that many men with
ponytail no it's not the late 90s or
lady
exactly you know but when you put women
in the game you've got multiple players
with ponytails and if they don't move it
doesn't look realistic so we've done a
lot of work around here simulation to do
that kind of in our rendering we need to
do quite a lot of optimizations there's
a lot of work there we we scanned a lot
of the players heads again to make the
most authentic look we've got animation
changes we had to rework ratings whilst
we still have a 90 rated player at the
rating systems changed to make it feel
better so that you know feel more
authentic to the women's game yeah
because the women's game does play
differently now cuz they're because
they're like I'm a massive arsenal
ladies fan prolific team yeah like when
they merged leagues a couple years ago
Sunderland ran away without the Arsenal
ladies have been fantastic and I watch
them on Arsenal TV but there is a
difference in in the the pace of the
game and then how it's played so
presumably I'm guessing there is no mail
and against females I think it's a
really good point we've kept it female
versus female male versus Mel again
authenticity you know in that case but
it you know it's really a very different
experience and that's one of the great
things the last couple of days as people
in play in it they really enjoy the
difference and you know they really
actually like how the women's teams play
and I'm really enjoying that as a very
different experience presumably now
you're stuck with it it's like every
time you guys add to FIFA and it's
almost like a sort of a difficulty in
being so popular and being so successful
is that you know you get a lot of stick
for not you know doing things by the
fans you know you need to tweak the game
but every time you add a new mode you're
basically adding a new mode for the next
three four five years right and
obviously you're you're 12 women's teams
in the game yeah and international I'm
guess basically yeah yeah best of luck
to the England their ladies now actually
lumbia right at Columbia the kind of
need to win that game win or draw in
there three to the next on yes oh okay
so as long as France stone yeah I guess
Mexico and anyway sorry give back to the
to the to the video game stuff and
presumably now since you've dipped your
toe in it you're going to have to keep
evolving on women in FIFA 15 feet 16 and
70 I mean obviously we're at his whim
into our game that they're going to be a
big part of our game moving forward you
know we'll see how it will look at the
reaction this year which has been
incredibly positive which is fantastic
but moving forward we'll see
I mean we'll make a decision on that you
know in the next year and you know if
we've got anything else we'll do that
next year but very very important part
of that game and as certainly as a team
we're very proud to be able to bring
them in excellent yeah it's wonderful I
think it's it's a great news for for the
sport and for video games as well lily
and sort of it on that point will there
be to calm the granular questions will
have any women in ultimate team this
year no nine altima team this year we
thought looked it but obviously quite a
big player Paul to such you know for
ultimate team for the motor work so
they're not an ultimate team you can
play and kick off yeah and you can also
set up international tournament cool and
you can also play with your friends
online online as well excellent and also
just talking about the in terms of the
women in soccer like what i felt i say
soccer actually because when i moved
over here a year and a half ago I joined
the league and it was a coed league
right and I actually was kind of blown
away by how big women's soccer is in the
state specifically because they seem to
have a much better handle on in terms of
like college soccer like it keeps
getting bigger and bigger for you guys
not only in terms of women but also in
terms of the North American market are
you seeing like different people playing
fifa because forever like going up I'm a
I grew up playing like sensible world of
soccer you stayed out to somebody in a
North American I'm a clue you say FIFA
apart from all the corruption stuff they
know what you're talking about do you
feel like like this like soccer video
games are becoming international finally
definitely I mean I think that you know
it's been really exciting to see the
growth in North America I mean you talk
about the women's game and you know i
live in canada obviously we make the
game in vancouver and you know you look
at the growth of grassroots football but
both for men and women but specifically
girls football and then both i have two
daughters they both play you know girls
football and it must be so likewise you
know it's the coolest thing for them
they're very excited but to see just the
quality of football being played the
coaching is phenomenal it really is and
you know it's really nice to help you
know the end of the day one image the
authentic game there is the growth of
the women's game the last five or six
years the quality of the football of the
World Cup has been phenomenal incredibly
exciting games but you know to see
football grow in general I think you
know it's really exploded in the last
few years we're seeing you know growth
of our game we're seeing you know
people enjoying football because they're
seeing the players that they know now
for playing fifa we're seeing obviously
football is on every weekend now through
NBC and I think that was a real tipping
point a move for the World Cup people
saw every four years now they're seeing
it every weekend we actually get more
football in Canada in up and in the u.s.
than we do at home in the end because we
can't see live games at three o'clock on
a Saturday and we can we get every
single game it's fantastic there but it
just means you have to get up and
ungodly hours I know the champions
league final in the FA cup final we're
definitely or four in the morning start
with the loss is not good ya dip between
F bettina Premier League and an f1 I'm
really in trouble and my last question
actually to that point I'd be wrong for
me not to say because a bunch of people
asking are you treating the MLS are you
getting like a bunch of our mls stadiums
in this year because obviously like you
play the Premier League it's great all
the stadiums are there now and what
about MLS you can do it but we're not
really going we don't go into details
about any licensing changes or things
that we're adding I I will say though
it'd be hard for me not to ignore the
fact i think we teach something in our
trailer yesterday i think there's an mls
stadium in there that we haven't
announced but um i think most people can
guess now which one that is awesome but
yeah there's obviously a new mammal s
stadium which is great beyond that will
it will announce things later on awesome
the kind of pleasure is ever going to
see you again they're great to talk to
you and looking forward to FIFA 16
actually when is it out end of sep
tember great just around the corner just
when the the league is kicking off again
our salon going to win the Premier
League next year I can feel it thanks
very much for watching us on gamespot
com on the YouTube at e3 home and of
course on hitbox we'll be back in just a
minute